D
ATTENTION WOULD HAVE KNOWN THERE
WAS SOMETHING AMISS HERE VERY
CLEARLY.
DAVE PORTNOY IS THE FOUNDER OF
SPORTS NET.
THAT'S REALLY THE QUESTION, YOU
ARE, I DENT KNOW HOW TO DEFINE
YOUR INVESTING BUT SOMETHING YOU
DO ON THE SIDE BUT YOU'RE INTO
IT.
YOU'RE NOT LIKE A TRAINED
EXPERT.
>> YEAH, FTX WAS A ADVERTISER OF
OURS.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE AN
ENTHUSIAST?
WAS THIS OBVIOUS TO YOU THAT
THERE WAS SOMETHING WEIRD GOING
ON?
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW IT COULD BE
OBVIOUS TO ANYBODY, A NORMAL
CITIZEN.
IF YOU SEE TOM BRADY PITCHING
FTX ON THE SUPER BOWL, YOU'RE
GOING TO BELIEVE IT'S A
LEGITIMATE THING.
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU WOULDN'T.
AS THE STORIES HAVE COME OUT AND
CRYPTO, I'M NOT PAYING A TON OF
ATTENTION, THERE WAS ARTICLES
THAT COIN DESK WROTE IT AND IT'S
SHOCKING TO ME AND I'M IN THE
GAMBLING FIELD AND RIGOROUSLY
WROTE IT AND IF I DO ONE THING
WEIRD, YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT IT.
THERE'S COMPANIES WRITING
ARTICLES AND WE KNEW THIS GUY
WAS IN THE BAHAMAS, WHY?
UNREGULATED LIVING AND BASICALLY
A PENTHOUSE WITH LIKE 20 PEOPLE
ARE RUNNING THIS AND HE'S
THWARTING WITH POLITICIANS AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT
AND THE FACT HE WASN'T
INVESTIGATED TO ME SHOWS A LOT
OF THE COUNTRIES ARE ABOUT.
PEOPLE MAKING MONEY AND BEING
DISHONEST AND SAYING THE RIGHT
THINGS TO MAKE MONEY AND HE'S
LINING EVERYBODY'S POCKETS.
IT WASN'T OBVIOUS TO ME.
BUT IF YOU'RE MEETING WITH
GENSLER AND YOU'RE MEETING WITH
POLITICIANS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IN A MILLION
YEARS THEY DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
IT WAS PRETTY OBVIOUS.
I WASN'T LOOKING FOR IT, BUT
ONCE YOU START GOING BACK, IT'S
LIKE HOW DID THEY NOT KNOW THIS?
AGAIN, CONTRAST THAT WITH LIKE
WHAT I GO THROUGH BECAUSE PEOPLE
DON'T LIKE ME, IT IS NIGHT AND
DAY.
REALLY IT IS QUITE STARK.
NO, NOT A NORMAL PERSON
INVESTING WOULD EVER KNOW.
THE GUY IS SPENDING MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS TO GREASE
THE RIGHT MEALS. MEALS.
>> Tucker: SEEMS LIKE NOW IT'S
FAILED IN THE SPECTACULAR WAY,
IT'LL BE USED AS A JUSTIFICATION
FOR MASSIVE REGULATION.
>> 100%.
YOU MENTION IT.
HE WAS THE GUY SUPPOSEDLY
HELPING CRAFT THE REGULATION FOR
FUTURE CRYPTO WHICH WAS INSANE.
>> IF WE LOOK AT THIS GUY AND
KIND OF CONTROL WHAT'S GOING ON
AND SIDE NOTE, THESE POLITICIANS
ARE DELETING THE PHOTOS OF THEM.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW YOU TOOK A
PHOTO FOR THEM AND DELETED THEM.
>> Tucker: HOW HARD TO CONTROL
PHOTOS ONCE THEY'RE ON THE
INTERNET IN >> LISTEN, NOBODY
KNOWS MORE THAN ME.
>> Tucker: I KNOW, SORRY.
>> BUT THAT'S PART OF IT.
I LOOKED AT WHAT THIS GUY WAS
DOING AND I WAS LIKE I CAN'T
WALK DOWN THE STREET IF I HOLD A
GIRL'S HAND.
IT'S A STORY.
WHAT'S DAVE DOING?
THIS GUY IS LIKE AN X RATED
MOVIE IN THE BAHAMAS AND NOBODY
CARES.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT JUDGE BUT
NOBODY LOOKED INTO IT.
IF HE DIDN'T DO THIS, NOBODY
WOULD KNOW.
HE'D BE THE ALTRUISTIC GUY.
NOBODY IS ALTRUISTIC.
ALL THE CRAP EVERYBODY SAYS
WHETHER YOU'RE A POLITICIAN,
IT'S FOR POWER MONEY MOST OF THE
TIME.
PEOPLE WANT TO GET RICH AND I
TRUST THE GUYS WEIRDLY LIKE ME,
IT IS ME.
I WANT TO MAKE MONEY.
I WANT TO MAKE MONEY AND HAVE A
GREAT LIKE.
MAKE MONEY AND GIVE IT AWAY.
HE TOOK A REASON TO TAKE A LOAN
FOR HIMSELF AND DOING WHATEVER
HE WANTED AND NOBODY TOOK TWO
SECONDS TO LOOK.
I TALKED TO HIM BY THE WAY WHEN
THEY ADVERTISED AND IT WAS
ALWAYS A WEIRD GUY.
THIS CHARM AND ALL THAT STUFF,
NO WAY.
HE WAS THE LEAST CHARMING GUY.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> NO, THERE WASN'T LIKE OH MY
GOD, THIS GUY'S SOME SORT OF
GENIUS.
MAYBE HE ARBITRARY WITH LIKE
MIT DEGREE TO MAKE SOME MONEY.
BUT HE WASN'T SOME CHARMING GUY
THAT YOU CHARMED THE PANTS OFF
PEOPLE.
HE COULDN'T CHARM ANYBODY.
YOU KNOW HOW HE CHARMED?
WITH HIS WALLET, MONEY,
DONATIONS AND THEY LOOKED THE
OTHER WAY.
THERE'S NO OTHER EXPLANATION FOR
THAT.
I'M FAR MORE CHARMING IN A
ONE-ON-ONE SIT DOWN THAN HE IS
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, I END UP AT
THE BRUNT END OF A HIT PIECE
EVERY TWO WEEKS AND THAT'S
BECAUSE I'M NOT OUT WRITING
CHECKS.
>> Tucker: IT'S UNKNOWN BUT
HAVING WATCHED THIS FOR AWHILE,
WILL WE EVER REALLY GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF WHAT HAPPENED?
>> NO, NO.
I MEAN, LISTEN, THEY SAY HE HAD
THIS RESEARCH FIRM THAT LOANED
HIM ALL THE MONEY AND THE
BINANCE GUY OR WHATEVER HIS
NAME, THEY WERE COMPETITORS AND
ALL CRYPTO AND SOME IS MAGIC BUT
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE'LL TRULY
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF BIG PLAYERS
THAT LOST A LOT OF MONEY.
I MEAN THE BANKRUPTCY TODAY,
WHAT THEY RELEASE SECOND-DEGREE
CRAZY WHAT -- RELEASED IS CRAZY
AND SPENDING MONEY ON.
WE'LL NEVER GET A STRAIGHT
SHAKE.
HOW CAN GENSLER SIT DOWN WITH A
GUY WHO IS LIVING IN A PENTHOUSE
IN THE BAHAMAS WITH 15 PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALL HAVING SEX WITH EACH
OTHER SPENDING MONEY ON
EVERYTHING AND HE'S LIKE, YEAH,
WE'RE GOING TO WRITE THE
LEGISLATION WITH YOU.
I MEAN HONESTLY?
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
I CAN'T TIE MY SHOE.
THIS GUY'S DOING THAT AND
GETTING AWAY WITH IT.
IT'S LIKE COME ON TO THE WHITE
HOUSE AND SIT DOWN AND MAKE SOME
LEGISLATION.
IT'S INSANE.
>> Tucker: YOU NEED TO SPREAD
SOME DONATIONS AROUND, DAVE
PORTNOY.
CALL MAXINE WATERS A